but you cannot see girl honey would this  be put in a judgment against Robert for  his back child support thing he hasn't  hey and are you yeah how long has this  been all stop pain last year yes  whatever we're going through as to  adults who got divorce have nothing to  do with you being a father you've been  it has nothing to do with you being in a  [ __ ] eggs-actly why don't you understand  that's real from what I read in the  tabloids and what I see from Draya  one-on-one of course is two different  things if you just never knew her story  never knew who she was you wouldn't  believe that she went through these  things in her life like it's that some  babies I got one so we can measure how  much three money a time you have to put  out you ain't bad child support but you  got enough money to have not one but two  live-in girlfriend no I almost lost my  house  you